feeding the news today is the story that  David Cameron is into you making a much  tougher offense if somebody grooms a  child and to sending them an  inappropriate selfie online it's part of  his campaign to try and get tough on  online pedophilia and it really does i  think recognize perhaps the growing  issues and dilemmas that come from  social media when the normal people  using science teachers instagram  facebook twitter and so on the other  thing that's in paper today is miliband  speech on the economy this is the  headline that he wants Miliband vows to  wield the axe but it should be pointed  out as well that at the same time  they're not going as far as the  conservatives would go on cuts because  they would still borrow for investment  and they're also being more flexible on  the time line for balancing deficit